okay thank you for coming that's in the
first place I will take it for granted
that as we are at PI data you will all
know what week supervision is but I
doubt if you know what snorkel is maybe
some of you will associate the name with
this particular item which is used for
snorkeling but don't be worried we won't
be talking about it but the goal of this
presentation is to introduce snorkel as
a tool for you and I will try to answer
some questions about how could you
potentially benefit from using snorkel
and what you can achieve from it or with
it but before I do so let me introduce
my team that I've been cooperating with
on the project that I will outline in a
second the key here is that it is a
multidisciplinary team and that's a key
factor that contributed to the success
or not of this project as you may see
most of them are biologists but my
presentation won't be that heavily
impacted by biology so it should be
comprehensible for all of the audience
here what is biological
at least in some extent is the problem
that I've been faced with so let's
assume that we are looking for useful
information for our research we have a
research question on bacteria namely
some strains of bacteria and their
relation or interaction with antibiotics
so we would like to know if a given
strain is responsible or susceptible to
a given antibiotic we are looking for
this piece of information in a document
it can be a scientific paper or a patent
but if we outline this project the
problem like that it's pretty
straightforward you just read the
document scan it look for the name of
the strain look for the name of the
antibiotic and you quickly you will
probably quickly find what is the answer
or if there is an intervention
interaction between bacterium and an
antibiotic we can slightly
complicates the problem by adding more
documents so you just retrieve more of
them you need to read all of them you
need to scan all of them whatever you do
just there are more of them that's the
key
but still it's probably manageable by a
person the expert domain that can
retrieve this particular piece of
information from those documents but let
me complicate it one step further and
add multiple strains then it's getting
more and more entangled but still we
have this hook the name of the
antibiotic that we can first retrieve
documents on and then search for this
particular word within the text of the
document and try to look if within the
antibiotic there is a strain in the
sentence and try to figure out what the
inter interaction between them is and of
course as some of you may think there is
the next step when we have multiple
antibiotics now its end-to-end problem
it's getting thoroughly difficult not
only on the step of retrieval of
document but also when you are reading
them you need to be focused on multiple
things at the same time and it's
basically not manageable by one person
or even multiple persons who are not
domain expert and let it put it into a
numerical perspective what I what do I
mean by multiple documents namely one
hundred and fifty thousands of them and
as I said previously they are they all
are patterns which are horrible lecture
you you are not going to read it they
are written in a particular style that
makes them a very heavy read and
scientific documents that were multi
where the information that you are
looking for may be mystified by some
irrelevant details
it's basically what I mean by that it's
heavy it's horrendous and you don't want
to do that so as we are at PI data you
may think of
this problem as a deep learning problem
so did I let's use deep learning AI
whatever you wish but and this is a the
most general view of typical machine
learning problem when and let's assume
for a moment that our algorithm that we
will be using for to solve it is a black
box we are at the moment not interested
in that what we are interested in that
you need some data to feed into this
particular algorithm of your choice
so you feed it with some parts and
observation and the corresponding label
but at some point you need to ask
yourself a question what are X's how do
I get them what do I feed my network
with and probably network you are all
thinking about that works a bit and
where do I get wise from that's still
not very mmm that's even more
complicated problem particularly because
we don't have any labels here I mean I
can know that there is an information in
the Centers but how can I convey how can
I bring this information to my algorithm
I a machine learning problem but let me
propose you a simple solution that some
of you may be persuaded with others not
but let's take us for granted that a
sentence is a career of an information
that we are looking for sentences where
our information resides and we will be
focusing on it as a unit of processing
one sentence will be our unit of
processing so we are particularly
interested in sentence when two entities
over 20 Disko occur one entity is a
strain of bacteria that we can recognize
by its name and the other one is an
antibiotic and when the per in a
sentence co occurs we have a very strong
indication that it may be a sentence
that of interest for us that's not
everything but it's a very good
beginning the more slightly more
complicated situation is with wise I
when I was preparing for this
presentation I came across not only for
this presentation also in the meantime
when I was working on my project I
came across these two papers that are in
the footnote of the slide that you can
come up with some ingenious mixture of
weakly labelled and strongly labeled
data and feed it into your algorithm in
both cases they were neural networks and
get the most of it and as you can see we
only need a small a handful of labeled
data and we can fill the gaps with
weakly labeled data but still a question
remains where do we get that 99.9% of
weakly labeled data from there needs to
be a good way to do it even more that's
a crucial part because as authors
especially of the second paper claimed
the better the quality of weekly weekly
we label data the better will be our
final outcome which should be no
surprise to you so I've made a research
on the net and I found snorkle the
outers of the stalker come from Stanford
University they have their own hazy
research laboratory that develops
multiple projects brought namely tools
and some of them may tell you that it's
a system for quickly generating training
data with weak supervision or that it
can help you rapidly creating modeling
and managing training data and that's
all true but I will tell you that it's a
Python module just like it is okay
before we move on let me outline to you
what a typical pipeline of snorkle
project may look like so first of course
we need some data it can be raw data you
can achieve it you can obtain it from
multiple sources whatever you wish
databases online you name it it has to
be structured in some way snorkel has
tools that can help you achieve that but
you can do it on your own once you have
all your raw data in a format that is
required by snorkel you can move to the
next part its document parsing we all
the people who are working at some point
with text data in machine learning it
that it's do know that it is a crucial
step and the sentences the text the your
corpus needs to be processed in some way
for my needs I was using spicy and as a
result of tokenization in the motivation
and some more steps we obtain documents
that are split into sentences and the
term sentence here not by accident
coincides with the our career of
information that I was mentioning
earlier one sentence here is a unit of
processing further on ok so we have our
documents parsed and ready and we have
sentences so let's pass it to named
entity recognizer to start with anything
in this matter we need to have purse we
need to have entity stacked within
sentences you may use out-of-the-box
tagger but I haven't an ever found one
no one talks bacteria or antibiotics in
sentences so I need to come up with some
some tools that can fill the gaps but
you need to have this ok so let's start
that we have happily tucked our entities
so we can process those marked sentences
for the run and we have candidates one
candidate will be we want to extract the
candidates that are of any use to us
so in the first place we are we are
looking for sentences where those 20
Disko occur as I said previously and we
eliminate all of the sentences where
there is only one or none and it is
marked in this way we obtain the good
candidates and now where the magic
happens or maybe not magic but at least
some heavy mass we need this notion of
helper functions those are very simple
functions written in Python as circle is
a Python module that can score your
candidates with the problem with the
research question that you have in mind
those questions those scores
don't need to be exact the need to be
precise but they should provide some
feel some indication on usefulness of a
sentence for your research question I
will come back to that in a second the
thing is that after you passed you
passed all your sentences through helper
functions for each sentence for each
candidate you obtained one numerical
vector comprised of n numbers that will
be used further on and maybe let's stop
here for a moment and what are those
minus ones ones and zeroes so circle is
designed in such a way that you can make
a helper functions to not make any
decision it obtains and then it produces
0 if it has if it doesn't know what to
do with the sentence if it is helpful
for you or not and as I told you we are
looking for interactions to accept
ability resistance to add an antibiotic
but that's not everything that we want
to know even better it would be if we
had a precise information if this given
strain with this given antibiotic in
this given document is described as
resistant or susceptible that's why we
have two directions in which we can
score we can great our candidate one
stays for for example resistance - one
for susceptibility it doesn't matter at
this moment and it's not relevant the
thing is that we can distinguish those
two directions which is for example
crucial for you as it may spare you some
post-processing time for the run ok once
we have our all of our sentences scored
we pass all of those vectors for all of
candidates to generative model and not I
won't let you be mislead by the name of
generative model it's a notion
introduced by the authors of snorkel but
for the sake of completeness it's not
generative model as for example in image
processing where you generate images now
it generates one label one label per
each candidate is called probabilistic
label that conveys information about
usefulness of these particular
candidates in your
as I mentioned we always have to keep
this problem in our head so it combines
multiple statistical tools into
something useful that summarizes somehow
those mmm those numerical vectors okay
but some of you probably could accuse me
after the presentation that it's of no
interest for them because I will be I
was talking about textual data and you
are working with images or something
else but please mind that the last two
steps go beyond text data in my case as
I was working with corpus corpora of
documents I really had text data but
what's the problem if you want to judge
send an image or a sound wave if only
you could come up with some functions
that will roughly great what you have at
hand and input it into a snorkel
disregarding all the previous steps you
can still go on with that too
the thing is that you will get one label
one numerical label for each of your
entities okay but as I promised I'm
coming back to helper functions because
this is probably the most important part
of the whole pipeline especially and
that I cannot stress that enough this is
the only place where you can input
domain expertise into the pipeline so
everything relies heavily on that all of
the previous steps were some some to
stop are to some extent standardized but
this one is where you can show your
skills to the fullest and what are the
correct or or what are the examples of
helper functions so for example in my
case when I was looking for resistance
susceptibility interactions I may ask my
sentence if it comprises words resistant
as having tact entities of both kind in
the sentence and additionally having a
word resistance means almost 100% sure
that this is sentence I'm looking for
if you are looking if you are designing
a model which will distinguish the
sports car from other cars you might ask
that the image of your choice if it has
a reddish patch in there because as we
all know some sports car only come in
red and so on and so on so what our
Harper functions do is actually they
help us get rid of wise whatsoever we
substitute our wise that we were
previously missing with some assessments
of our sentence that we provide as input
to our very general algorithm but not
not the end there is still generative
model generative model as I as I was
trying to convince you by this time
accepts only heuristics no as helper
functions you can provide everything you
wish let it be heuristic let it be
pattern you can in make as an input
distance supervision which is you can
compare something that you found with
already existing existing external
database where some data was curated you
if you pushed crowdsourcing to solve
your problem but you know that the
results are not perfect just put it into
generative model finally that's very
precious if you have domain experts that
can help you with assessing some
sentences at least let's use them let's
ask them questions and try to input
their responses into the model and
finally but not ultimately we
classifiers they are easy to run they
can quickly give you some very rough
estimation of your sentence and they can
be easily included into generative model
so how does our generative model plays
in the diagram that I've shown so it
basically takes all of the helper
function input generates one label and
some of you may ask what is the issue
why do we do that
if it's necessary at all so the outers
of the paper that i will show in the
second as i think and as like as I
remember argue that including generative
model a augments results by five percent
and it's not something that you can
easily native neglect especially that
it's not that time-consuming this step
is pretty pretty quick so now you have
one sentence and a numerical score for
that sentence once you are in this
position you might do everything you
like using your favorite algorithm for
to solve any problem that you have okay
but I said we are at paid data I was
referring to the data part now to the PI
part so let's talk briefly about Python
so what is snorkel on technical side so
it's an ORM software which is also some
kind of bottleneck for it but I will go
to at in a second where the result of
every intermediate step of the pipeline
that I've been showing is stored in a
database so that's why we have this SQL
alchemy as an interface in between we
have also support for spark clusters
that if you want to help have your
calculations distributed and there is an
easily easy integration what I didn't
tell you that for a problem like mine
where you need to extract information
from Rho text there is embedded model
into snorkel that enables and this
problem to be solved in end-to-end
fashion the final neural network is
written in Python but it was previously
written in attention flows the packet is
still evolving the last commit were not
even a whole month ago snorkel provides
embedded support for two natural
language processing frameworks namely
analytical and spicy but what is
relevant for you and it was crucial
for me you may substitute any step
within those within those processing
tools with your own and that's why I
could come up with custom entity
recognition mechanism and it was devised
as Jupiter notebook tool which makes it
easy to run and finally of course
multi-processing is is insured because
otherwise you wouldn't deal with one
hundred and fifty thousand documents
what are the downsides on the other hand
I would like to persuade you that I'm
not paid by Stanford to to sell it to
you it's free by the way so I've also
noted some some downsides when I was
working with it and I don't know if you
agree but my data was quite considered
quite considerable in size that's what I
think this tool wasn't ready for because
it doesn't have for example or maybe I
will skip to it in a second but first
thing that I was struggling with is that
the solution is pretty inflexible every
change to it is a burden that you have
to carry so it's not straightforward not
at all to make any changes in the very
engine of snirkle
and as it comes free you can make any
changes you want the second thing is
that because of the SQL alchemy that was
that is incorporated in the pipeline and
it is heavily incompr incorporated the
load bit is very very low so you can
enhance that and there are ways to do it
I did it but by default it's not perfect
and what is even more troubling for some
of us is that whenever you have some new
piece new bunch of documents coming you
cannot append it to already existing
database you need to start afresh and
recalculate everything which it is silly
at least for the initial steps of the
pipeline where the model is not involved
but it can it can be overcome and
finally everything is written to work
and in an in-memory fashion which makes
calculation or
think of corpus of documents like mine
impossible to do it like from off the
shelf product so I had to make some
alterations to it and chunky five for
example documents to be of a certain
size that fits my memory and doesn't
throw an error with that so these are
these are the most relevant tips that I
can give you as a practitioner of
snorkel and by no mean Evangelist of it
okay so my presentation is ready I
didn't expect it to go that fast so I
think it leaves us with some QA and time
if you have any questions thank you for
the presentation this might actually be
really useful for my work I have one
question regarding the need for the
database do the X did they explain why
they need a database and not just ok
there is a data frame you passed a state
frame and okay I know what you mean I've
been considering it as well if it's
already if it's at all necessary but
maybe if you have a second photon it it
may be useful for you because otherwise
you would have to store it somehow all
the whole corpus of documents you have
how parsed corpus of documents let it be
I don't know if you would like to pickle
it or store it in data frames and it
would be quickly messy very messy you
wouldn't you would have difficulties in
tracking which steps of the pipeline are
stored in which data frame or in each
file and of course you may
strip the whole pipeline of the data
base altogether
especially if your corpus is relatively
small but I found it useful when you
enhance the speed the load of the data
into the database it can be you can live
with it and then everything is coherent
inside the database so I was also
skeptical at the beginning but as the
time went by I was starting to like it
even more
I just have one additional question they
use generative models one of the things
let's consider Bayesian networks it's ok
an example if depending on what data you
use you can update the priors and
posteriors so you need in what is
confusing me is that you need to
recalculate the entire thing again but
you are using a generative model so it's
kind and that's the caveat that I
haven't made it's not a generative model
as as you would like to would it like to
be now it's a statistical based more
than much learning base I don't know if
the the distinguished before between
these two attempts is very slight and I
don't know if you get it but you don't
use any machine learning algorithm there
it's pure statistics where some in
interdependencies in between the helper
functions are exploited in order to
generate the best possible label so you
take into account possible correlations
between helper functions how this core
you take the coverage of each helper
function if it is very if its course
much of your data or very tiny pieces of
your data and if it tightly overlaps
with other helper functions this is the
generative model that they are using and
not a Bayesian network that's why
probably they need to start everything
afresh because what generative model is
about is finding some parameters some
weights that you impose further on on
each and every helper function so that's
why probably needs to be started afresh
but as I said it's not crucial because
it's not the most time-consuming process
most consuming most time-consuming part
of this pipeline so you are good to go
with it any more questions
maybe I should have been a little bit
slower maybe there wasn't wouldn't be so
much time for questions if you have text
in another language that is supported
for by your language processing tool you
may use it it's language indifferent as
long as it has for example in spice you
have multiple languages so you can use
every that is supported by them question
did you had a chance to compare the
results generated by the week's
provision which annotated data so with
the ground truth as you have I hate I
had I couldn't show it because it's
intellectual property issue but I had
and that's another tip from a
practitioner I'm not by no means an
expert in biology I could come up with
some helper functions I was very proud
of them I I wrote like sixteen or
eighteen of them and you you know if
you're not in domain expert if something
it means something to you and I run on
those helper functions the whole
procedure and I've prepared a very small
corpus of annotated sentences before
hand and I was curious how do they have
the Earth's Court eventually after the
generative model comes up with a label
for them and the results were deeply
disappointing so out of fifteen or
sixteen sentences that are notated only
four would be caught up by the model to
be of interest for me and the good thing
is that it's I'm sorry
the presentation is gone it's irrelevant
at this point so what you can do is to
write some helper functions let them
score the corpus of candidates that you
have and find out if they are
interesting to you if the insight that
they provide is interesting to you
currently when I was doing it circle
didn't have tools for that but in
version 0.7 they introduced some tools
that can help you
make some reasoning about helper
functions on the fly so you don't have
to run the generative model but you can
run all the helper functions against
your candidate and check if the quality
of what you get is satisfying and I've
made a second iteration I've improved my
helper functions and then only then the
results were fine okay thank you thank
you very much I'm afraid we're running
out of time but I'm sure you can catch
our speaker during the coffee break
thank you very much big applause for our
speaker
[Applause]